suspect allegedly on an anti-muslim rant
cause there's my call hatred you get out
to the country that he doesn't like
rustling she stabbed them to death to
stab them with it
stab stab stab that's by a billion cuts
so start shoving the knife in ladies and
gentlemen he stabbed them to death
Oh on our show dirty [ __ ] a word
applause we're going to race for space
we're ready
giving a Nazi salute and yelling racist
expletive I want all Muslims deported
now you call it there's my all hatred
Jerry
young women one of them wearing a hijab
boarded the train and Jeremy Christian
immediately went on a hate-filled tirade
I want my listeners to hunt them down
all right knock akita yeah yeah there's
only one word a messenger of love
[Music]
there's only one where Jesus was his
messenger allah assalamu alaikum
welcome to the Dean show I will have so
how you doing the day I brought it back
again how you guys doing I'm little oh
no I like a lot thank you guys for
stopping in being with me here on the
Dean show Abu Hafsah we saw each other
on few years back yeah
how you been since then I'm glad we're
all still really waiting to be on your
show Nam I'm I'm traveling fundraising
doing all my stuff yeah you know how it
is that's the kind of I haven't wrestled
in a while but I used to do that as the
wrestler right yeah I was a shooter in
high school huh Ashley I was a shooter
in elementary school yes which is real
wrestling if you want that then I was
the first blind person to be accepted
into professional wrestling schools I
did that for a little while first blind
person to be accepted into question
arrest professional wrestling school yes
sir now is that like when you say
professional is that like WWE or is it
yeah that's Talia that style okay how is
that there's a lot of that stuff you
know how much is it's fake I mean how
much of it is real when you all the
buddhas i had were real yeah there are
certain things that are scripted yeah
like the outcomes and everybody knows
but don't we need to all that stuff is
real yeah I know exerting a lot of Finny
yeah if you pick someone up and slam
them yeah you know there isn't a whole
lot you can do to fake that you know
yeah but there's a storyline behind the
storyline the winners and losers have
been selected
yeah on that story model that's where
it's fixed up yeah that's what it's kind
of fixed up it's it's it's it's what is
it's more it's more real than a movie
but less real than mm-hmm you know they
mean do it's kind of like that what they
call it Broadway love body slam
yeah Broadway with body sensor so when
you're out there you know you have to
and accidents happen to people literally
get hurt and negative been broken and
people have been killed
yeah when it's very dangerous or it's
very dangerous in spite of the fact that
it's it's um choreographed to a certain
extent yeah you know your body is your
body you know picked and the ring is
made out of steel and wouldn't you get
slammed on that it tends to hurt just
little they had a head of a documentary
live ass everyone many of these
professional like stars there were with
the WWE was a WWE what's that the main
guy Ed McMahon what's this a man Vince
McMahon okay and that matter the
gardener you win prizes on ya Ed McMahon
mo enterprises yes yes yeah with the big
chef Vince McMahon is the other one well
the one of the wrestlers that were with
his organization many I think that was
Jake the snake Roberts and his life they
go he was a big star and many of them
you know they end up turning towards
drugs and alcohol and they had the you
know all the stardom and everything you
can just imagine but then on the flip
side many people don't see how they just
come crashing down well yeah because
you're let's say for example you're on
the road for them 220 days a year right
you're on the road to 20 maybe 300 days
a year you're traveling up and down and
you're fighting every day like if you
look at the average career of a boxer
Mayweather was at 49 and Oh someone
clear since we had 49 fights in his
whole career professional wrestler
whether it's choreographed or not has
more fights than that almost in a month
so you can only imagine like three four
thousand flights every day
choreographed or not your body's going
through the motions of fighting every
single day so you have a lot of pain
issues you have a lot of pain
medications that you need to take or
that you may need to take and oftentimes
you don't have a doctor prescribing them
for you at least not back then so you
take matters into your own hands and you
self-medicate
which leads you to like you said your
drugs and alcohol and what you can't buy
in the pharmacy you buy in the street so
you know it tends to spiral out of
control for some people and for others
it hasn't had that effect but you're
right they tend to come crashing down
unfortunately now you say how many
fights in a month that they really have
let me try to do it about 25 a month two
more nights like tomorrow and that's
every day your body is getting slammed
slam slam slam and like for example okay
you're going to be in Chicago on Monday
night so you wrestle at the United
Center is the United Center so all
states and also at arena hmm so you
fight there and you drive three four
hours to another city and you fight
they're Tuesday and then you fight three
or four hours in another city on
Wednesday then you go home for a couple
days and then Friday it starts all over
again
that case keeps going going going going
it's a continuous thing where you know
continually fight and then if you get
hurt you jeopardize the other guy like
let's say if me and you are fighting on
tour together me and you so right me and
Eddie for a month I get hurt the first
night in Eddie now doesn't get paid
because I can't work yeah so what do I
do I don't want Eddie to suffer because
of me so I end up having to work hurt
which requires medication which sends us
right back to our own demons and people
spouting out of control yeah and then
really and then really living for just
you know neg okay you're wrestling your
superstar and that's all you're living
for people praising you right you're
fulfilling every lust and desire that's
the problem but the heart and soul is
empty that's a whole other ahold of yeah
right Wow sorry so now we have that so
you have all the temptations of the road
right the women is the alcohol all that
other stuff and now the women are
wrestling so maybe the men are the
temptations of the road there's so many
different stuff going on again you're a
star you know stars take like they had
on this one wrestler and he always says
you know I I'm a star in front of
everyone but I wake up alone in the
morning you know so you have a lot of
issues like that you know and you
believe what people say like everyone's
praising you that you're the best
fighter in the world when really you're
not because the winners and losers have
been chosen for you yeah so if you put
some of them in a real fight you get
hurt you know because it's not exactly
real so if you believe that reality then
that's another issue that you have
you're not the best fighter in the world
you know you beat me because I let you
beat me it might not work that way if
you know what I mean yeah and I beat you
because you let me beat you so may not
work that way if we were alone and
there's no crowd so there's all these
different stuff and having did that when
I was in wrestling school I was still
speaking and we could do another time
probably my whole story is a whole
different thing but we I was speaking in
front of people and I was working in
mate facilities and different things
that nature and I
accepted into professional wrestling
school so when I was there I did about
two months to three months in wrestling
school and my oldest daughter Hafsah my
oldest blood daughter I have a
stepdaughter was a bit older but hafsa
is my oldest and she was really missing
me a lot and then her mom calls me and
she says well you're about to be dad
again and you say buzz my youngest and
she was coming so I thought okay it's
time to like you know you made it to
wrestling school maybe there's going to
be another blind person that's going to
take this a little bit further but you
have two daughters that well too one
daughter and one potential daughter
that's going to really miss you a lot so
I came on I stopped doing it so that's
good you you are you ended up you could
have went down that direction writer
yeah promoters were upset because I was
um you know the blind guy that can run
the ropes and do all the different
things that the Prussian Russells can do
and make it look semi-legit like people
wouldn't believe that I couldn't see I
was literally because my eyes aren't
real their prosthetics so I would
literally have to like take them out to
show people okay I'm actually blind yeah
because I could run the ropes and I
could do these things that decided
professional wrestlers could do you
would have sold some big tickets me I
would have probably able to promote I
very well I'd be on a game show yeah I
mean this is it bro I'm happy to be here
so it's all good yeah you would have
been on the Vince McMahon ticket right
and many most people were in that line
of work or you know celebrity
statistically they have a greater chance
their numbers of suicide are much higher
many people they don't understand it
because many people chase that dream
they want to be a star and you forget
about really seeking purpose they forget
about you know the most important
questions in life and they say they just
chased that Fame and that money and
stardom and you look at many of these
people's lives and at the end of the day
these people they don't have what you
found in Islam well you go ahead that's
the thing I one of the one of the key
because I made my sorrow when I was in
less in schools out of the Sahara is
when you pray to a lot and you ask him
if this is good for me then let it be
for me and if it's not and I'm being I'm
paraphrasing for the sake of time but I
made my source of the Sahara and
like this older professional wrestler
who was I I was the ring announcer for
the for the Federation that I was
training under hold it hold it right
there don't lose you're going to take a
break we're going a little time we're
going to take a break and you continue
right there
we'll be right back with this is amazing
they are amazing two guests here don't
go anywhere right back please don't
forget to like and share also do your
best to help us reach our goal for more
info check in the description below and
in the words of jesus Shalom Salaam
peace be with you
back here on the Dean show in the VA
and Hausa tell us so we'll continue
where you left off well I paid my slots
at this too hot oh so you were your you
know your your Al's Muslim since 1996 I
was always Muslim in professionals in
school ah she rose in 2005
yeah I got accepted into that finally so
I was Muslim all radios Muslim for about
11 years nine years up until that point
actually and I prayed in my Salah to mr.
hodda where I'm asking a lot you know if
this professional wrestling deal is good
for me then allow it for me it was good
for my dunya and my Asura from my
current life and my next life then allow
it for me and if it is bad for those two
things then not to allow it for me and I
met this older professional wrestler so
he's asking me we're having lunch
together before an event in Halifax Nova
Scotia where I was working as the ring
announcer you know they're introducing
the wrestlers now yeah all right in this
corner this is Eddie right that guy how
was that guy for a luma so he brings me
up and goes you know you don't seem like
you're stupid
so I said to me literally zip it good
you seem like you're kind of smarter so
I want to talk to you about something
so do you have any kids and I said yeah
I got one I got one on the way he said
well you may win a lot of belts in this
industry but one of the belts you'll
never win is father of the year bro
Wow ouch I don't like that that's the
only one I want it has only real belt I
want I don't care about anything else in
this life anyway I want father of the
year you know more father of the century
if I could get it from my kid so he you
know he kind of ruffled my feathers with
that one and he said you're gonna travel
up and down the road with these same
guys and they're going to become your
family and then you know you might make
it you might be among the 1% of us that
actually makes it or you might be like
me and tear you both meniscus is out and
end up carrying bags for these guys
and I really hurt me because I'm a
Muslim I don't want to put my body
through unnecessary hell just so that I
can tear my both meniscus is out it is
your knee cartilage and end up being a
suitcase carrier for wrestlers I don't
want to do that
so that was my to me anyway that was the
answer to my prayers as it were my ex
Takata I booked my ticket about five six
days later I said goodbye to the
promoters and he got really upset
because again I could told you I was I
was a meal ticket potentially for him
and for myself yeah and he's like just
gave me ten years bro please like just
stay with us for ten years you're gonna
be able to buy all your kids anything
that they want it's very tempting huh
well not really because I'm thinking I
don't want to take cortisone shots yeah
and you know but the way they sell it
back you tell it you're gonna be a star
you're going to buy all everything you
want you can have everything in that
mind you know and you're going to do
this so imagine if you did have is to
how to imagine you didn't have that
connection to your that is um you know
that anchor right I got to look back to
like I know that a lot can give me much
more than that without exactly i
meniscus is out yes all right so I I
just I booked my flight and I went home
and I raised my kid with the help of a
lot on me and their mama no longer
together stuff like that happens but we
still get along and we're still raising
our kids together so there's that at
least and now I do this I travel up and
down the world
you know I've been on every continent
without having to Brussels and beat
people up every day or get beat up every
day you know we met a few years back
like you said I've been to Africa I got
married in Kenya I would live there for
a year learn Swahili learned a bit
mumbled on when I was over there to get
some down were there Guyana South
America all up and down the US and
Canada and England and Ireland and
Australia and all these cool places
without having to do any of that so a
lot replaces something with something
better and perhaps you like a thing
that's bad for you and perhaps you
dislike something that's better for you
I didn't like leaving professional
wrestling I really didn't but I like
this a whole lot more because my knees
are were there supposed to be and my
neck is where it's supposed to be I'm
not addicted to anything except maybe
ice cream um Tim coffee
I'm doula so we're good in that regard
and and and I'm healthy my brain is
where it's supposed to be and you're
doing so much more rewarding yeah I mean
this is it you get to inspire people and
and invite them whether they accept the
invitation or not to the worship of
Allah and that's really
when you need to invite the people to
the worship of the Creator instead of
the creation we're gonna have a lot of
things in this life man
paradise is not going to be one of them
at least not while you're here mm-hmm
like if you you know you could have the
big mansion in the big house and that's
fine if you get that in the hell that
way masha'Allah
I don't like poverty Eddie I don't I'm
not a fan of poverty at all but if the
dunya if this life is in your hands
don't let it be in your heart you know
yes that's what's important if you can
catch the people who are wealthy can
actually do what the famous people talk
about meaning I could tell you about
building mosques I can tell you about
giving to the poor I can tell you about
donating to orphans but the rich people
can actually do that if their mind is in
the right place that's the thing about
Islam is it gives you that priority yes
you have money here a lot of the
companions of the Prophet SAW said I'm a
wealthy and they have money they had
immense wealth many people in history
Mansa Musa and people like that had
immense wealth but it was in their hands
not the heart Jenna was in their heart
the pleasure of Allah was in their heart
and that was much much more important
for them than to have this like black
credit card all these different stuff
yeah what do you guys think now you've
uh you've actually went above and beyond
both you guys you have gone on to really
study Islam and depth I'm holding a book
up here called and I often tell people
look you know if you know the basics of
Islam if you don't you know and you
think that Islam has something to do
with much of this mayhem that's out
there the madness you need to read the
Complete Idiot's Guide to understanding
Islam because if you have a genuine
understanding of the basics right I just
said yeah bye yeah yeah emmerich it's a
great you have your have you ever met an
expert we have a flame-broiled there you
go yeah as I totally read books radio
yeah but it's really basic I've had and
I hope because because it's very
important you know anyone who has the
basic essential understanding of Islam
you've gone above and beyond that right
you you lecture you're on the lecture
circuit you talk with you know
not yet Muslims Muslims everybody
homeless everybody who listen right both
you guys but what now when you have
these obstacles in the way things that
happen that do not benefit Islam at all
that are against Islam that Islam
condemns recently there have been some
events that have happened again and what
are your thoughts when these things when
you're reading or you know you're
listening to the news and then you're
like oh and don't let this be someone
who's associated somehow with being a
Muslim that whole thing of like most
people most common sensible people they
know that every way of life every
religion even name any of them as cults
and has bizarre people in it for lack of
a better word
we have bizarre Christians who thought
slavery was a good idea at one point and
brought you know 20 million Africans
over here and not only them they brought
Irish people over here they did so many
different things and they don't
represent Christianity and we don't say
that they did we have Greenpeace people
who will you know the people that like
the trees yes they will hammer nails
into trees and then paint over it with
green paint
who's that when you come to chop the
tree down and you know anything about
chainsaws when the chainsaw hits a nail
that could eat that could kill you
yeah right so you have people like that
to go above and beyond way too far you
have people who who are Orthodox who
think that anyone who isn't like them
should somehow be killed or subjugated
and we don't we don't believe that and
any common sensible person knows that if
1.6 billion people were to set it off
the world would not be the same and
that's that's something that people need
to understand now for Muslims especially
us and living over here in the Western
countries the one thing that we need to
do more of and I really call us on that
is giving back to the people that live
here people don't care how much you know
Eddie until they know how much you care
so if you're out telling us you know
telling people you know what Islam isn't
Tom isn't terrorism Tom isn't violent
Islam isn't mayhem Islam isn't murder
Islam isn't this isn't isn't isn't all
well what is it then yes what is it can
you show us what it is
Oh Islam is the peaceful submission to
the will of your Creator okay but what
does that entail it entails good deeds
fair enough but then when mr. cat comes
around most of it doesn't go to the
American people and our around here that
need it that may need it we have
homeless people here news we have
homeless Muslims here you know we have
newcomers to the country who just got
here
who don't have anything and who don't
have any way of helping themselves and
we need to help them we have new
converts the reverts if you will to
Islam that often times get ostracized by
their families and get thrown out and
get left on park benches and things like
that we need to help them I'm not I'm
not against sending wealth outside the
country but I think more of it needs to
be spent here for a couple of reasons
one we live here and we need to plant
where we live
right so the people can actually see
what we're doing for them we have
thousands of mosques quite literally how
many hospitals do we have how many
hospitals we have umpteen thousand
doctors everybody in the grandma is a
doctor right number some community right
doctor so-and-so doctor doctor doctor
and that's great but how many hospitals
do we have of our own we have so many
engineers you can easily build the
hospital in this country so that the
people can come there and get and get
state-of-the-art health care that they
can get taken care of by the Muslims you
know chief American Center what's wrong
with that The Healing Center call it you
didn't want because people sometimes get
blown away by Arabic words called the
healing center healing hospital call it
that Allah is the one who heals
ultimately but you know he gave us the
ability to help a lot of people because
what's going to end up happening is if
you're going to change the people's
minds in their hearts you have to do it
without with with your efforts speaking
is great we have a job to do when we
travel doing that but at the same time
if the people aren't actually
benefitting the society around them then
they have no real complaint when that
society doesn't know them Yeah right
yeah they're so actions huh actually for
all of the worlds we're going to take a
right action we're going to take a break
and right back with more here on the D
show don't go anywhere
caring and sharing so like and share
this video and support the Dane show so
that we can continue educating and
sharing the message of peace peace is
acquired by submission to the will of
God it's not with the world
a Centon alaikum peace be with you
back here on the Dean show actions speak
louder than words is very important what
you just said and have you had people
that have you've had a chance to talk
with and they try to you know they've
been manipulated by the propaganda and
have you ever had any stories and how
you would vote for any of you guys last
night last night yeah yeah I mean some
people share with us what will happen
well they tend to read and believe what
they read even though it's like part of
verses or you know a segment of the
Quran like if you want there's an ayah
that that talks about often seems to be
the lot to fight for the sake of Allah
now if I just leave it there and that's
an open-ended statement you fight for
the sake of Allah okay who do you fight
autumn see said be Delilah Davina your
party new nakum fight for the sake of
Allah those who fight you so you have
the right even in this country to defend
yourself
Americans pride themselves on having
that right that doesn't mean now you go
to a concert
and you harm 12-year olds because you're
upset with foreign policy it doesn't
mean you go to a bridge or in harm
people on that bridge or you go to
Manhattan and harm people in Manhattan
people that may have not fighting with
you people in a concert aren't fighting
with you people standing on a bridge
enjoying the night aren't fighting with
you so we like to say things and take
them out of context and this is what
people have when they have their agenda
their anti-islam agenda as it were yeah
they don't like us for whatever reason
and this is their agenda right they're
going to build walls and ban people and
make life difficult and interesting for
a billion-and-a-half you know segments
of society so this is what ends up
happening so people because the work is
not being supported as much as it should
tend to get more of this than that
alright so someone says something
against Islam and he gives five thousand
retweets 100 thousand retweets in some
cases someone puts an eye of or on he's
lucky to get 3 likes mm-hmm you know so
the Muslims have to stop promoting this
kind of stuff you know one of the
easiest ways to get over in Hollywood is
to make a film about Muslims
because Muslims will promote you for
free mm-hmm Muslims will get irate get
upset whip out start tweeting start
facebooking about why the video why the
movies racist why the movies anti
Islamic why the movies which is
interesting because we can't really be
racist because we're all we all
represent every single race but how the
movie is Islamophobic and anti-this and
anti-that and then of course the Muslims
are going to go how is it Islamophobic
so what do they do they put down their
remote smartphones they go buy a ticket
to said movie and watch it now we have a
conference let's say coming up let's say
this weekend tickets are $25 who's going
to attend that conference
unless there's free food very few people
actually attended in comparison to the
multi-million group of people that are
going to come hollywood to watch you
know usually other actors who aren't
Muslims portray us in a bad way yeah we
have to start promoting this work and
promoting it better than we've been
promoting it so that people will not be
as confused as they were and is his
story is quite common I see it you know
relatively old quite regularly wherever
I go where he'll say the Quran tells you
to kill he'll tell you that Lauren tells
you to kill yeah but it also tells you
to care mm-hmm and then he's like and
I'm like how can it be both you know how
can it be both so he starts asking
questions and nothing was talking him as
well and we got him to an understanding
where a lot of the confusion that that
he knows about Islam or thinks he knows
about Islam is just that miss confusion
do you think most of these these people
like that you come across there they're
getting their education from the
mainland and sources from a negative
source that's the first problem right
and yet opera agenda well now you're
getting now you're hearing all of this
false propaganda you're getting your
information from the wrong source and
now of course you've been misled as long
as we are not talking to each other and
letting people talk about us we have a
problem what do you think obviously we
can't be naive to the fact that there
there are individual sick individuals
twisted individuals and
and they on both sides that ended up
doing some things that obviously are
against Islam so Islam condemns these
actions the one that you absolutely I
mentioned but tell me can we be naive to
the fact us also be noted that in recent
months in Europe they've been a number
of false flag plots where right-wing
extremists have tried to frame is honest
for a terrorism we've seen that in
Germany in recent weeks but I love the
underwear bomber the list goes on and on
the drugged-out guys one of them was
certified mentally [ __ ] at 93
bombing the World Trade Center the FBI
cooked the whole bomb they go out and
find [ __ ] Street people okay
mentally [ __ ] people and that's
that's the al Qaeda
you know al Qaeda goes from these
precision aircraft with their
transponders and beacons turned off one
out of a hundred commercial pilots
couldn't t-bone a building perfectly
without their navigation system these
guys line-of-sight never flown in that
area never flown a commercial plane
flying straight in magically to passport
stripped down proving it to them and the
hours after with multi feet of dust all
over lower Manhattan and the FBI finds
two passports magically I mean come on
come on come on that there are also up
I'm not saying that everything that
happened happens that we say oh okay
this is set up this is fixed up this is
but in election this week is so so the
thing is is it is it being naive or
should we not be naive dat because there
are people who call out these things
these are Americans also who also they
want more evidence they also say that
there's an agenda here that this has
that basically many of these things are
fixed up us also be noted that in recent
months in Europe they've been a number
of false flag plots where right-wing
extremists have tried to frame a service
what do you thoughts on that yeah I mean
it's possible like any anything at all
but sometimes not not I'm not saying
that we should believe all but without
what I'm saying and I've and I've heard
that that we shouldn't be naive to the
fact that potentially because there have
things invention history you know there
have been things that have been set up
Alfa Tonkin in Vietnam exactly bigger up
and cost eighty thousand people in our
cattle life because obviously Muslims
don't benefit from this Islam the
benefit it is so now you have Ramadan is
coming you know what in the world I mean
you're going to be breaking fast with
your family you're supposed to be in the
mosque worshiping with your family
worshiping with your relatives you know
you're enjoying it's supposed to be a
month of the car ah and you're over here
trying to like kill people did doesn't
add up it doesn't make sense it seems
that it seems that whenever it comes to
certain events like this people don't
care about the fact they may see the
dramatization of it all on the news and
and we all know how whenever something
happens like this an attack happens
that's all you see on TV there is
nothing else in the news cycle
except for that so so people get caught
up in the dramatization no one really
looks for facts no one really looks at
what was really going on you have so
many different conflicting views of the
events witnesses they're saying
completely different stories but then at
the end they settle on one story and
that's what gets played and that's
that's what everyone goes with mm-hmm
you know no one really cares to look
deeper in regards to in regard to
certain events just like you said we're
not saying everything is set up
everything is put out there to put the
Muslims down but it really seems fishy
that a lot of the events do seem to
happen at specific opportune times there
was the one that happened with Muhammad
Ali
but after his janazah oh it's Lamas
getting you know so much so much greater
publicly publicity and then just said
that just interesting just you know and
the partying I thought of like of course
Muhammad Ali just died oh yeah it's
something like this hat but interesting
what do you think I'll have so is you
know when you're faster you know how you
feel you're fasting you don't have much
energy you really want to be efficient
with your energy right yeah so now
you're fasting you're not at your
optimal strength where in the world I'm
just asking questions right we can't be
too naive that there there are Muslims
there are people who have
the the Muslim you know cloak in the
name and whatnot and they might have
they might do some crazy tits again
Islam is free of it if every Muslim is
drinking alcohol if every Muslim was
fornicating if every Muslim was doing
all the evil that's AAPIs to Islam Islam
is free of it is is correct of course
but what I'm just saying I'm just asking
questions like what kind of Muslim who's
supposed to be fasting where do you get
this strength and the zeal to go ahead
when this is the month of the Quran it's
a month of really just spiritually
uplifting yourself to be a better human
being where in the world do you would
you get garna this this this strength to
do something evil like that well this is
the thing oftentimes what happens with
happening like you said it could be
there could be certain things set up as
we say we shouldn't be naive to anything
at this point
but even if you read the stories of the
people that were quote-unquote
accused of these things oh you used to
drink and smoke weed with us and then he
became religious six months ago it's
like really six months ago I've enlisted
20 years like six months ago what can
you possibly learn in six months you
know that that hasn't already been
dormant in that person for the last 22
years of his life like people who you
know come out and all of a sudden
they're going and shooting up no
nightclubs in Florida used to frequent
that nightclub before and then now they
became ultra-religious quote-unquote and
now they become crazy and do things that
are not crazy on our next word they
become destabilized for whatever reason
and do things that they're not supposed
to do but it's very interesting that
white people white men can attack people
and they're lone wolf mentally ill
they're mentally ill they're mentally
disturbed
we attack people quote-unquote and it's
a large worldwide conspiracy to control
everything it's very interesting how
that works and it's all terrorism
whenever a Muslim doesn't - I mean you
have the you have the guy that attacked
those those people in Portland aremy
Christian police say this man verbally
attacked a Muslim woman on a train and
that when good Samaritans came forward
to help he stabbed them to death
I want all Muslims deported now
step in puck undercut the nose all right
knock Katina - stab them with it
stab stab stab yes by a billion cuts so
start shoving the knife in ladies and
gentlemen white supremacist accused of
stabbing two good Samaritans to death on
a commuter train in Portland first half
in the neck the other than stomach a man
identifying himself as Jeremy Christian
I'm God dude on our cylinder speaks a
word of God we're a quasi fake Christian
giving a Nazi salute and yelling racist
expletive young women one of them
wearing a hijab boarded the train and
Jeremy Christian immediately went on a
hate-filled tirade then pulled out a
knife and attacked them then I see that
there's just blood everywhere looked
like every punch that I saw was actually
a stab
police say 53 year old Ricky best died
at the scene and 23 year old talisha Nam
KY may say was pronounced dead at a
hospital
Jeremy Christian you call terror to my
call hatred to your non-muslim white
island with a benign white guy attacked
non-muslims which which were actually
standing in defense of the sister of a
Muslim sister and another assisting
humanity and and he slaughters them in
public and then further with all these
people
but he's mentally ill psychologically
keator ecologically disturbed the word
terrorist is not used once the first
time I've ever heard it used with the
non-muslim like that is when the men
went into Quebec City and he shot the
people in the measured our prime
minister called that man a terrorist and
I thought that was noble but it's just
one time it's one drop so we need to and
it's emotional to like when people see
okay it's kind of like if we're living
in a house and someone comes in attacks
that house emotionally it's our
emotional response to fight back that
right but when it comes to emotions we
need to kind of put them on hold and
find out what's actually going on when
someone's guilty in court they're not
guilty because you think they're guilty
they're not guilty because you want
to be guilty they're not guilty because
they look guilty they're not guilty
because someone else said they're guilty
they're guilty because evidence has been
brought against them and without a
shadow without a reasonable doubt
they're found guilty we have to look at
people the same way individuals do
things individually and we can't put
them on one specific group if a white
person goes and kills people in Portland
he doesn't represent all white people
but no one needs to say that because
that's never been said about him because
white folks don't come on mass and
apologize for this man's you know act
and the same with anyone who attacks
concert goers or anyone else that these
people don't represent anyone except
themselves and their own twisted logic
and that needs to be put whether it be
the IRA whether it be groups like Isis
which is the crisis whether it be groups
like the KKK whether it be any any kind
of group that promotes hatred or or
anything against other people they
represent themselves in that specific
group because 1.8 Muslim 1.8 billion
Muslims that's a big number you know
that's a very big number that's the
population of India pretty much so do
you guys leave them everywhere have you
guys noticed that I mean usually the the
Muslims were usually like no let it not
be we're like we're like worried like
there's not that people think people
think like so you're already you're
ready to give a response cuz you know
we're on the same page but yeah I'm like
way out in troubling but but then but
then it's like what they're trying
people are trying to portray the Muslims
like oh they're happy because of these
things but actually the people who are
salivating they're like you know they
just can't wait for something like this
to happen so they can spew this hate
rhetoric is the Islamophobes and
Islamophobia machine have you noticed
that you notice they like love this
stuff they're aiming overall where
Muslims are actually like coming
together and and raising money for the
victims and you know doing some
something and you may get a blurb of
that MINUSTAH very I felt like it's not
like they're going to spend so for
example an attack happens right and the
first 24 hours of coverage where
nothing's really clear terrorist
terrorist terrorist terrorist they find
out it's not a Muslim then you make it
five minutes the next day and it's
dropped you know so it's definitely a
situation where as well as soon as we
hear something happens the first thing
that goes through I can I can assume
that this is most Muslims is please
don't be a Muslim please don't say it's
associated with the Muslim yeah I get
that all the time I know it's gonna be
and then to white guy so I'm like I'm in
trouble again because you've been now
how long have you been studying Islam
the Quran you actually you quoted some
Arabic so you're you're fluent in Arabic
also not the only but you can you your
peer yeah have you have you've memorized
a great portion of the Quran or all of
it not all the way you know a great
portion of it so basically you
understand it very well you've studied
under some great scholars and you've
learned from for many awesome good
teachers some good teachers okay
so making me look good at ease like a
lot so now so now you you with someone
who you ended up converting reverting
whatever the case how you know you'd
like to use the word you've come to this
beautiful way of life when people try to
say okay Islam is the motivating factor
right they forget about again Islam
condemns these actions even if we know
this is like a geopolitical thing this
is not you know this is motivated by
other things that these people they end
up losing their their themselves in
whatever but what do you say what would
you say if you had some where they
brought you on in the CNN Fox News and
then they try to say no this is Islam is
the root of all this because Islam is
inspiring what do you say with someone
who's really like you know you've been
studying it for how long now I've been
with some twenty years twenty years now
what would you say you know this the
thing is there's no we're really in
Islam that gives you permission to kill
noncombatant innocent people so Islam
can't really be the inspiring factor
ignorant is the inspiring factor I would
say that among other things because you
find a lot of these people when you
study their BIOS written by is
infinitely enough all of a sudden when a
person doesn't attack they know
everything about him well if you know
everything about him shouldn't you have
taken them into control before he did
that but interesting though but in any
case you often find these people don't
know anything about their religion they
don't
they became practicing three months ago
or they became practicing six months ago
or eight months ago and before that they
were drinking smoking weed
you know fornicating doing whatever that
they want to do then all of a sudden
they're Holi and they become these
martyrs if that's the case 20 years of
more people who become Muslim 20 30
years ago 40 years ago shouldn't they
have done it quickly because I mean 20
30 40 years you'd find something that
would permit you to do some stupid news
like that was based aslam was the
primary motivation there's a lot of
there's a lot of primary motivations for
lots of things but since the people are
dead you can't ask them right they're
gone so yeah then what was your what was
your prime motivation he can't ask you
no more he's in a million pieces
somewhere there already could have been
a motivation marginalization could have
been a motivation low self-esteem could
have been a motivation a mental illness
there's one that could have been a
motivation that probably was the motive
you're not actually imposing so we don't
get people people people having people
having a nice gathering in Afghanistan
or Iraq or hanging out and a drone
missile kills off their whole Flamm
family that could be motivated and I am
sending the United States and some
people were picking panda so that's that
right so again Islam doesn't justify
taking you know innocent life but people
don't really talk about like Robert Pape
and many academics they talk about this
is based off foreign occupation this is
like so what would people do they don't
think like if if you end up you know
sending a force over here from China or
Russia right and how would the American
public react you follow me that people
people these these people it's ironic
usually because we have there's
perimeters in Islam but most of these
people that spew off these hate I can
just imagine what kind of day if they
were able to what kind of havoc they
would be doing what kind of murder and
mayhem would they be doing Muslims are
not even allowed to do that you know if
the enemy you know inclines towards
peace even if you have to do it
you're supposed to incline towards peace
Allah Allah says in the Quran God
Almighty says don't make mischief in the
earth
don't be extremists everything opposite
to what they're trying to connect Islam
with but you know what's amazing about
Hassan is that people
we genuinely look into Islam when they
hear all the events and they don't want
to be puppies they don't to be suckers
they don't want to be fooled bamboozled
and they look into it
have you noticed they end up many many
they end up accepting Islam or they say
oh this is a lie man they defend Islam
well that wasn't even sense the time of
the publicís bob was one of those
genuine people yeah genuine people get
it because again like I don't talk too
much about the Middle East I really
don't because it's hard for me to
imagine what a person goes through who
locks his entire family I can quote you
verses all day if I want but if you lose
your entire family may Allah protect
them it's a come on bro right you go
home let's say you went to a market and
you go home and you have a wife and four
kids or five kids and your father Eddie
you know that another you're a father
I'm a father like we get it you know you
come home and see your family literally
in pieces in the rubble of your house
there's no rational way you're going to
handle that
there can't be it's a mental you get you
get a mental breakdown when that happens
to you and you forget what you learned
in Islamic school make quite possibly
you forget what you learned that the
message did you forget those things and
we're supposed to hold to the Rope of
Allah and we're supposed to be patient
with what Allah has given us but it's
easy for people over here to say that
when we're living in relative comfort I
can be patient all day because I'm fly
back to Canada and go back to my house I
don't live there so it's very important
for us to establish these kind of things
and understand that it isn't ever
justified to take between excuse me it
isn't ever justify to take innocent life
we need to find out okay what are these
people going through one of the people
and even the ones that live over here
what are they going through that makes
them susceptible to these act to doing
these things not they mentally ill are
they just just bad people are they just
misunderstood and misunderstanding
things and confused are they poor are
they chemically imbalanced like there's
so many different things that would
cause people to do that so all they need
then is one of these people to just push
them a certain way so you see you're
you're oppressed because Americans
oppress us which is not true generally
your prior years marginalize because
they don't like you because you're brown
or because you're an immigrant which
isn't true generally it isn't true
does it happen sure but is it is it the
rule of the day no not every American
hates you because you're an immigrant
but you just need one person to point
you in a wrong direction and then you
take it from there and this is
unfortunate because we do have
provocateurs in our community with this
mentality that all Americans are evil
and all the country is bad and
everything is bad and we don't believe
that either just like we don't believe
that Islamophobia you know is preaching
right things about Islam being violent
and extreme we don't believe that when
Muslims tell us Americans are all evil
people that's ridiculous and they don't
take either of those positions and
unfortunately like right now for example
our hostages made some statements right
that that he was explaining that this is
it what's right but we all know
someone's gonna watch this video I hope
not to him do paint clips heavy you know
what I mean and say oh look at what
they're promoting unfortunately and I've
seen it yeah and just so you know I've
never promoted that 20 years on on on
traveling up and down the world
I've never promoted anything like that
and I'm not saying that it should be
promoted I'm just saying that people go
through stuff that makes them a little
bit off sometimes and it's very serious
when you lose your entire Center when
I'll give it up but if you read the
Complete Idiot's Guide to understanding
Islam you know and you watch danger and
you know they yeah you are a teacher you
know that it is not Islam is free of
what people end up from all these things
well we're about to come to a close that
now yeah tell us give us recite to us
recite to us and it has to do with the
heart but when some people they are they
can see but they're actually you know
God Almighty Allah talks about the
hearts going blind
give us something for Ramadan some some
heart softeners because that's what we
need at these times you know this much
of this hate that's out there hardens
the heart but the crown softens the
heart right well I like the ayat where
Allah described himself mm-hmm and that
always softens in my heart yeah when the
world is kind of chaotic and crazy as it
were I like to go back to the one
worship and the one who who guided me
towards this way Jesus worship know who
Jesus worship - yeah Moses all the
listeners will get all this and there's
a lot of worship ending with my thoughts
on the press peace and blessings be upon
them all and this is actually what
brought me into Islam and this is what
keeps me in Islam is the way a lot
describes himself and I'll recite it for
you and then we can close in sha Allah I
want to come back to Dean show sure you
gotta come on man yet all my friends on
its bring a stack inshallah the end of
surah number 59 well we said we say
we'll be in a shape on your lodging
novena on Iman morning what Shahada t1
wanna know him o Allah Allah Allah
medical caduceus sanam Alemany : what
you do so ceremony on Mohini neologism
Jabbar will take a beer so the hon Allah
he I mean I shrieking Allah will
Harlequin burn it you know so we don't
have asthma
[Music]
Oona's now you shall be whole again asss
annawadi 100 who was in his own
mashallah so this is the verbatim for
people who are tuning in the night yet
Muslims because everyone has the
potential to submit to the crater alone
and not his creationist or the Muslim is
one who submits themselves to the
courageous like Jesus did and this is
the last and final revelation sent to
mankind the Quran verbatim word of God
Almighty so what what was the
paraphrasing what was the ayah that you
recited talking about it was the end of
surah number 59 the last three ayat from
that surah where it says who a la una de
la illaha in van who he is Allah and
there is nothing worthy of worship
besides him there's no other gods
besides him Allah lima why he was
Shahada that he is the knower of the
unseen as well as the visible what Allah
command over him and he is the
especially merciful and the entirely
merciful Allah Allah Allah Allah Allah
who he is Allah there's nothing worthy
of worship besides him and medical
caduceus set up he is the true king the
holy the source of peace was inching me
enough we say Salaam alaykum to each
other all the time which means made the
peace that can only come from Allah be
upon you one of his name's is a Salam
and what we mean on Miami no magazines
on Jeb bottle to get there the preserver
of faith and what men and women I'm not
sure the meaning of that and I see some
Jabara the the mighty the compelling and
the kept build the proud and he is one
long holiday light level and men called
producer Solomon omaima's he's in Jabbar
omaticaya
Subhan Allah I mentioned that he is
perfect and high over what they ascribe
unto Him which we were talking about
that earlier all these crazy acts and
different things of that nature Allah is
free from all of that war law was hard
it was valid that he is a lot he is the
creator the fashioner the whole last mat
when I first met and to him belong the
most beautiful names and attributes the
Homolka Semmelweis he was other than he
is the sovereign over the heavens and
the earth well as using Hakim and he is
the mighty and the source of all wisdom
this is Allah I paraphrase and I know I
made some mistakes in that but this is
you know and I read the noble quran
chapter 59 you know the land of it shall
be broken
weave
who can hook up with you guys they want
to Islam by touch and working to get a
hold of us
Apple has declared gmail.com mm-hmm
that's for bookings that's ready you
want to invite you out to do a talk or a
university comment blech that's what he
can get home there and shall declare at
gmail.com not to brought me out to
support his project so he can let you
know if I do my job or not staying alive
in the esslyn by touch comm you know our
whole goal is we want to reach out to a
group of people that no one's been
reaching out to when we want to change
the narrative for them as well yeah one
last one last question in short
just what at the end so you you
attributed you accepting Islam
submission to the will of the creator
dedication and having to do something
with the Quran having to do something
with this ayah and well in a nutshell
tell us what was it the deciding factor
you have to go against all odds I just
need 30 seconds do it in a meme or there
so but just what was something a piece
of it that just finally said you know
what this is the truth because there's a
lot of people procrastinate
procrastinating you know when you talk
to people about Islam you know the
oneness of the Creator the messengership
you know accountability Paradise
Hellfire period you know all of the
things make sense the Quran never change
never corrupted intact everything makes
sense but then people procrastinate what
had you ting procrastinating you're here
you're happy right you're living purpose
what was it and people can take from
that and they can run with it like you
did you know the idea that a lot is not
like his creation Lisa come in Tony
Hsieh so you can't make a statue of a
law you can't make an image of Allah
Allah is not black a lot of not white a
lot is not any of the things that the
people describe him as being and he
describes himself in such a majestic way
that I was drawn to that I learned
initially about Islam through cosmology
Shabazz gelada otherwise known as
Malcolm X and that was his core message
after his pilgrimage that you feel like
a complete human being and I just I
wanted to be like that and that's very
very short my story's like an hour long
but that's we're okay thank you guys
yourself Aloha thank you so much for
being social
thank you guys for tuning and subscribe
if you haven't already share mash the
subscribe button
yes master and support the D show her
don't smash it that's my connection
lightly good when I supposed to smash
the newer touch it very lightly back
like this is reach over with the mouse
is though Wow hit it very lightly hit it
and hitting no hitting come back every
week here to the D show and support the
D show we're doing our yearly campaign
support as much as you can so we can
continue educating and share this
message of peace and purpose with the
world so I'm a-goin peace be with you
please don't forget to like and share
also do your best to help us reach our
goal for more info check in the
description below and in the words of
jesus Shalom Salaam peace be with you
there's only one word a member with his
messenger of love
[Music]